A moment comes, which comes but rarely in history...
...when we step out from the old to the new.
When an age ends...
...and when the soul of a nation, long suppressed,...
...finds utterance.
Build courage when courage seems to fail.
Gain faith when there seems to be little cause for faith.
Create hope...
...when hope becomes forlorn.
I never learned how to tune a harp or play upon a lute,...
...but I know how to raise a small and obscure city to glory and greatness...
...whereto all kindred of the Earth will pilgrim.
The great questions of the day will not be settled by means of speeches,...
...which are already decisions,...
...but by iron and blood.
I have witnessed the tremendous energy of the masses.
On this foundation,...
...it is possible to accomplish any task whatsoever.
The future belongs to those who believe in the beauty of their dreams.